so talking about Trump and sort of
running on emotion and not policy and
kind of given everybody everything they
want and being to the left of what most
conservatives are yet still winning the
Republican primaries and all that you
had an interesting moment that you
touched on right at the top the
etch-a-sketch moment of the MIT Romney
campaign where basically you were on CNN
and you questioned was it Romney's
campaign manager who was it just
communications director Eric Fernstrom
okay and basically you said him you know
you guys have been saying all this bad
stuff about each other and the
Republican primaries and how do you move
forward that was sort of the gist of it
and he said well it's an etch-a-sketch
right and you can just sort of forget
all that stuff and reset do you want to
clean up the mess that I just created
for you there no you got it I mean it
was it was pretty it was a bit sneaky on
my part because I I knew that I wanted
to ask a question that I hadn't heard
ask before and at the time everyone was
saying is Mitt Romney conservative
enough that was the that was where all
the mainstream media was going you've
got Gingrich and Santorum is Mitt Romney
really conservative enough because main
most mainstream media will never stop
chasing Fox News's audience and and my
whole thing was isn't Mitt Romney too
conservative hasn't he hasn't he painted
himself into an ideological quarter in
this campaign by you know it was easier
to run against McCain in in 2000 but now
it's these guys in 2008 I'm starting in
2008 now in 2012 you know you're up
against Gingrich and Santorum you're
trying to be something you're not and
it's the same problem that every
Republican nominee is gonna have for
quite a while when the Tea Party is
control when you're nominating process
it's sort of like the GOP is gonna have
a tough time getting non lunatics
nominated for president Democrats have a
different problem nobody shows up to
vote midterms so both parties are kind
of screwed and that's why we're looking
at potentially a generation of
Democratic presidents and Republican
congresses but you know I so I asked in
a very wordy new zbs kind of way and to
my shock he came out and said oh no you
get to the midterm you get to the
general and it's like a reset button
it's like an etch-a-sketch and
I couldn't believe it he had just
admitted that MIT Romney had the
ideology of the guy from memento looked
like a crack house mattress he ain't
efficient like a like like a yoga
teacher untainted math and I went home
after the taping I was doing mornings
every day on CNN and by that afternoon
the clip had been shown everywhere I was
sitting out in a cafe with my wife and
baby and I saw myself on TV everyone
began running it was on The Daily Show
and Colbert that night and all the big
networks I was getting calls from Europe
and to sketch sales went up I believe
16,000 percent on Amazon that night you
get a cut of that I did not kind of kind
of that but I was assigned lots of edge
of sketches for the next two years at
every one of my tour dates and I guess I
was proud to be a minor historical
footnote but you know it is the sort of
thing Republican voters mean and
Democratic voters as well need to be
wary of especially in a season when so
many don't trust Trump or Hillary right
so basically what you did with that
question was you pulled the mask off of
the endless [ __ ] because you
basically said to him you had to say
some stuff to get through and look the
Democrats have the same problem I get
you with the Republicans and the Tea
Party they've dragged them to the right
I think the Democrats have the same
problem now where they're being led by
the far left and that goes to the point
what we were talking about with Hillary
where they are gonna demonize her and
then depress their actual people from
from showing up so I think both parties
have this problem but you expose this
thing and it seems like four years later
Trump has just blown the whole thing
apart like there is no more we have to
pretend we're this or that Trump is just
like I say whatever I want you all love
it and I'm just gonna keep doing it even
if I change my position every week yeah
and he will continue to change positions
he's already done it this week I'm not
so sure that Bernie has led the whole
party to the far left I kind of think
Bush and Cheney push the country a lot
more left to tell you the truth and I
don't think Bernie Sanders has said
anything too outrageous he's really
advocating for things that have worked
in other countries that are our
capitalist allies and for things that
have worked here in the past under
President Eisenhower well interestingly
I don't think that Bernie necessarily is
leading it but I think that that
movement that's behind
is leading him in a way that I don't
know that he fully grasps I think that
some of the social justice stuff and
just the the behavior of the far-left is
not behavior that he uses I tweeted once
I wish that I like Bernie supporters as
much as I like Bernie I think he is a
pretty decent guy but I think he's being
led by the by
I don't think he's being led i think his
campaign is being tainted by some of his
followers but that's fair in
circumstances here number one we have no
idea how many of these online trolls are
actually Republicans pretending to be
Bernie supporters to wound Hillary mom
tells mom always said don't talk to
strange eggs alright yeah talk to any
eggs with twenty followers because there
are trolls and you know there's
LeBaron's them as a whole basket also
you know a lot of these same situations
apply to Hillary Clinton supporters as
well there is uncommon hostility towards
Bernie supporters from tons of Hillary
supporters and the generational divide
in Hillary Clinton's campaign has been
fascinating you know there been studies
showing that that women over 45 have
waited their whole life for a woman
president and they've worked for this
and they need they really want this to
happen and I respect that but the same
studies show that women under 45 know
that in their lifetime there will be a
woman president and they'd all go for
Elizabeth Warren in a second
they don't totally trust this woman
candidate so it's it's a real reckoning
that our country is gonna have to face I
kind of have inclined to believe day
that whoever gets the job is gonna be a
one-term punching bag because I don't
know who could enact the kind of
sweeping reform we need to actually
restore the middle class we're sort of
in the golden age of gradual improvement
that's hailed as sweeping reform I think
if Bernie Sanders was smart if I was
advising him I would tell them to take a
one-term pledge and then just say that
once he got in there he was just going
to executive order us into having a
middle class again and then leaves I
think it's the smartest thing to do what
Trump is done wouldn't you be okay with
that really a the executive branch
getting more and more power because
almost every president at this point
takes more power for that branch and
even if you think about the emphasis
that we put on the presidential election
they're only a third of the government
right but we barely ever talk about
the Senate in the Congress right we
barely talked about the Supreme Court so
the idea of giving the president more
power do you do you fear that because
somebody that you didn't like could then
get into office and you wouldn't be
happy about it right filibuster reform
you know I mean all the Democrats who
are demanding that Harry Reid and the
filibuster you know when the Democrats
had the Senate yeah there now so
grateful they didn't because it gives
the Democrats some leverage yeah we've
never had this level of obstruction
before and in Congressional history Bill
Clinton broke the record for the most
filibusters against the president in the
US history he had more than every other
president combined and under Obama it's
already topped Clinton and Obama's first
term in Todd Clinton so this isn't I'm
not talking about big government I'm
talking about good government and you
know I know that things move slow things
are designed to move slow but I just
spent a couple years of my life working
on a film for PBS about the American
dream we retraced alexis de tocqueville
journey in 1831 and interviewed over 200
people in 55 cities and 17 states about
what the American dream was and what it
is now and it's one thing for me to sit
in a radio or a TV studio and be lofty
about this but actually having been on
the road for a couple of years the
American Dream is not what it once was
we were raised to believe that we were
in a country where you could work hard
play by the rules and you would prosper
and your children could know that they
were gonna have a higher standard of
living than you after 35 years of
deregulation of outsourcing of
deindustrialization of automation of
jobs being shipped away that are never
coming back and that's not the American
Dream anymore it's gone from prosperity
to survival for millions retirement
doesn't exist anymore the middle class
is now just the top of the bottom and it
doesn't have to be this way
and if policies got us here policies
could get us out of here but I fear we
being the slow learning monkeys that we
are it's gonna have to get a lot worse
before it gets better
yeah that's been a theme that I've
talked to a lot of people about that a
lot of people that I really respect and
like are saying that it's gonna get
worse before it gets better and
everything you just described whether
you are on the left or the right
it explains both Bernie and Trump
because it's about people are voting or
at least expressing themselves about
the broken system not the policies
that's why it doesn't matter what Trump
says he's just saying something and for
the Bernie people it doesn't matter
whether the president actually has the
authority to do these things and change
the banking system the way he wants to
and all of this stuff and the minimum
wage thing which the president can't
just do with a pen so Kennedy talking
about it as a platform or position so
it's just you know if you vote for that
it's the American people saying that's
what we want but we know that we know
that the government doesn't care about
democracy go back to Obama look what the
American people voted for twice closing
Gitmo American people voted for a public
option the American people voted for
higher taxes on the wealthy Obama had to
wait till he was elected twice before he
could just restore tax codes to Clinton
levels you know they run on these things
and then of course once they're in
office they're not allowed to and I'm
like well what about the will of the
voters so that that does come into it in
the case of Trumpets fascinating because
he's proved once and for all that nobody
hates Republican politicians more than
Republican primary courts right and
there's something sort of beautiful
about that that's why I'm conflicted
about the whole thing because it's like
I don't like the idea of this person
that I don't know really what he
believes in and and is using the media
in such a crass and sort of dishonest
way and then at the same time all of
these leaders I wasn't a fan of any of
the mainstream Republicans beforehand so
watching them all kind of crumble and
watching all the talking heads on all
the cable news networks watching the
same people who got everything wrong six
months ago now now they're afraid right
you can see fear in them when I watch
them on yeah I watch them on CNN and I
go wow you could tell they're afraid for
their jobs now because they've all been
phoning it in for years for the system
and now they're afraid wow this guy can
come in we could be out of a gig exactly
I mean watching the Republican race is
like watching Batman V Superman I don't
know who I'm rooting for I just wanted
to be done and and you know in that
sense it's revealed a lot of the
discontent we can't forget that the
first ever third party president got
into the White House with only 38
percent of the vote and he was a
Republican and it was Lincoln and the
two-party duopoly is what
a lot of people don't trust and you know
maybe Trump could have done better if
people run as a as a third party
independent although he did that before
I believe and you know didn't get
anywhere with it but you know that was
before he became a reality TV star right
um
it's interesting IIIi guess if I was
advising the Republican Party I I think
the smartest thing we've heard comes
from William Kristol which um you know I
know what kind of liberal are you I have
broken clocks that are right more than
him that the fact is William Kristol is
leading this consortium of Republicans
trying to persuade a mainstream
well-known Republican leader who's out
of the game to make a third party run
their fear is that even more Republicans
are gonna stay home this year then
stayed on for Romney in 2012 let's not
forget Gary Johnson
two-time elected governor of New Mexico
who was only invited to I think two or
three GOP debates in all of 2012 yeah
ran as the Libertarian Party candidate
got a million votes mark my words Dave
Rubin Gary Johnson's gonna get more than
a million votes this year and they're
terrified of more disaffected
Republicans staying home so the movement
and the New York Times were whole piece
about it is to get say a Rick Perry to
run as a third party knowing he'll never
get it to fall on his sword but therapy
fear is that Donald Trump is not just
gonna cost him the White House they're
writing that off there that are afraid
of losing the Senate so if you can get a
Rick Perry or an attractive well-known
conservative to run to at least get the
social conservatives out of the house so
they'll still vote and then vote are all
the way down tickets that could help
them save the Senate right we shouldn't
be saying this because I want them to
lose the Senate but it is a smart
strategy god it's such intricate little
moves and machinations of the system and
that you're agreeing with the ideas of
Bill Kristol to sort of take down
trumpets I don't it was the idea but I
think it's a smart idea if they want to
keep the Senate right so I like that you
brought up Gary Johnson I've had Gary
Johnson on the show I think he is an
extremely decent human being I've
watched I think I was one of the two
people that watched the libertarian
debate what's your line on libertarians
you've got a good line on libertarians
got a bunch of lines of libertarian
there
that something or no and I think
libertarian is just Latin for
embarrassed Republican I like that like
at you don't know they're like my cat
just like like look I know you're too
stupid to get this we'd all just be more
selfish dicks oh look a food appeared
magically before me and I did nothing
for it I'm that special and no one else
had a role in bringing my food to me you
want annoying ran book I've got anymore
you know I mean you know what I had the
I had the president of the Iran
Institute on last week you're gonna have
to watch the show maybe I'll have you
guys on together to battle it out love
to yeah I mean look how Somali are doing
the fact is even if a libertarian became
elected president which won't happen
you are never first off you can you can
believe in religion and science you
don't get to claim you follow Iran and
Jesus okay and Rand Paul by the way ran
away from libertarianism faster than
iron Rand ran to the mailbox for her
Social Security check
no president is ever gonna want to be
the president who does away with Social
Security and Medicare and Medicaid and
the entire social safety net right uh
it's never gonna happen so those those
types of things though it would just be
if you're a purist libertarian like
every party there's ways of taking the
sort of ideals of libertarianism of
limited government and freeing up
business more and things like that
without necessarily destroying Social
Security and still allowing for some
safety net and things like that so it's
yeah yeah I mean you know we'll see I
mean I'm a I like dr. Jill Stein of the
Green Party as well I I would love to
see at least one debate where all the
third party major third party candidates
get to be on the stage with the big two
because what we're seeing here with both
Bernie and Trump is a massive American
discontent with this you know snake with
two heads
that's taken over the whole game people
don't trust the two-party system and
believe me we're all gonna be so sick of
seeing that picture of the trumps and
the Clintons at the wedding laughing
together because it's the ultimate
signal of just how there's there's us
and there's them and most of the
Republicans and Democrats in this
country are part of the US yeah well
that's also why yeah I had Gary Johnson
on the show but I've tweeted several
times and I've tried to put the message
out there that even if you
love this guy even if this isn't your
guy if you guys get him to 15% once the
general election is on they have to put
him in the debate so it's probably not
gonna happen for Jill Stein because
she's run what 72 times already but
Garry Johnson I think this year what
once of course she's wrong only only
once before okay 173 whatever it is but
Gary doesn't I do think there's such
discontent that there's a chance that at
some point they could just get him to
15% and they'd have to throw another
voice in there so I'm not even making it
about him as much as just give us
another voice give us another option
someone let us hear another idea
honestly if the DNC wasn't walking
around in clown shoes they would pour a
lot of money into the right-to-life
party because there's so many social
conservatives who only vote for the
Republican Party because of the abortion
issue the Republican Party will never
allow abortion to become illegal it is
their number one fundraising tool and
trust me
as long as politicians have mistresses
abortion will remain legal in this
country and I can talk about that issue
all day long but you know to me why more
conservatives don't bail on the
Republican Party and go ahead and vote
right - like if you're already a
single-issue voter and by the way a
grotesque hypocrite because Jesus spoke
out against the death penalty never
mentioned abortion
technically the least pro-life character
in the Bible but that's a whole other
matter right to me you know the Bush
family was never against abortion rights
ever again support Donald Trump's not
against that of course you know they put
on this charade they shuffle it around
and these social conservatives I mean
Alabama keeps voting for these people
over and over and over again and nothing
changes Howard Dean was really smart
with a 50-state strategy when he ran the
DNC and a smart charismatic Democrat
would try to make inroads down there
trust me if social conservatives who
watch Fox News could hear a Bernie
Sanders speech unedited they find
themselves in the hunting every bit as
much as they do with Trump only with
Bernie it's policy with Trump ins just
personality so how much of this when we
talk about the personality thing that I
really believe this election is gonna be
won on the personality thing and not on
substance in any way how much of this is
just the times we live in it's just that
we're all that Twitter expressing our
sells all the time it's all that
everyone's on Facebook posting articles
and fighting with people and banning
people and muting people how much is
just noise do you have trouble I mean
when you're doing your show even sort of
separating the noise from what's
actually real yeah but I think that's
nothing new I mean you know look back to
how vicious Jefferson Adams were against
each other in the press
I mean Adams called out Jefferson for
selling his own children into slavery
200 years ago
you know Lincoln was so despised
Roosevelt and Eleanor were as hated as
the Clintons are all of this rancor is
really nothing new for our country or
our species and I think that you know
the like George Carlin said when you're
born you get a free ticket to the free
show the trick is to not grow up and
join the Freak Show and so um you know
yeah there's a lot of folks who are
gonna have to patch up a lot of
friendships once this campaign is over
and uh you know I appreciate my
conservative and progressive brothers
and sisters who were able to talk about
this stuff like grown-ups and not let
hate get in the way yeah there's not
many of us though or I guess there are
but we're the silent majority that's
what I said at the top of the show that
I think actually most people don't feel
like you have to have a purity a
political purity test to be friends with
someone but there do seem to be sides
that want that to be and I think
actually most people are willing to do
this and say all right Fugelsang said a
couple things that I agree with and
Ruben said a couple things I agree with
and and that's all right and that's the
people right I think you're right so
we've only got a couple minutes left who
do you think's doing it better than us
is there a country that you look at
right now because you know Europe's got
a whole slew of other problems Western
Europe and Eastern Europe we there's all
over the world there's everyone's got
problems
is there any system that you could go
those guys that's that's the way we
should be doing it well sure I mean
there's a lot of people who are doing
the American Dream has become the
Scandinavian dream and those are
capitalist societies with strong safety
nets where you pay higher taxes but you
get stuff for your taxes here we think
we pay low taxes but we pay high fees
for everything else yeah you might pay
lower taxes than our European friends
but then you're paying for your health
care you're paying for your senior care
you're paying for your college loans for
the rest of your life Michael Moore is
coming on my show today here at Sirius
XM
and I highly recommend his new film
nobody saw it it's called where to
invade next and the idea that is him
going to different countries and
stealing there are good ideas and
claiming it for America because these
other countries do the American Dream
better than we do there's still upward
mobility in these nations in London and
and Sweden and of course Denmark which
is considered the happiest country in
the world you know I believe in America
though I'm not going to abandon this
country for another one and I'm gonna
stick around here and fight for decency
and love and common sense I was gonna
ask you another question but that's kind
of a pretty decent way to end the show
Johnny well thank you David's the
pleasure to be here I hope it wasn't
i'll bring lots of dick jokes next time
I promise yeah next time we'll we'll
work blue and I look forward to coming
on your show again and you as I said at
the top you are the one that drags me to
stand up I need to be doing more
stand-up so Dave you really you're
really good on stage you keep doing a
lot more of it we need your voice out
there in the in the theatres as well as
on the air well that's exactly how I
feel about you so I want to thank my
guest John Fugelsang for joining me on
the show today you can hear more of John
on tell me everything every Monday
through Friday from 2:00 to 5:00 p.m.
Eastern on Sirius XM insight channel 121
Johnny thank you for doing this and next
time we'll get the Skype times right and
we'll work it all out and you'll be in a
fancy studio and you'll look great and
all that good stuff
I appreciate and I'm also on the road
touring across the country right now
I've just made my 21st out of state trip
in 2016 already I want to thank you and
the entire team that puts your show
together I love what you do I love the
show it's great to see what you're doing
out there and I think that you're an
important voice and I just want to give
my respect to everyone who works to make
your show happen